ed whitton
is often brought up as one of the most
brilliant mathematicians and physicists
ever
what do you make of him and his work on
string theory
well i think he's a truly remarkable
figure i've
you know had the pleasure of meeting him
first when he was a postdoc and um i
mean he's a
just completely
amazing um
mathematician and physicist
and uh you know he's
quite a bit smarter than just about
about any of the rest of us and also
more hardworking and it's a it's a kind
of frightening combination to see how
much he's
been able to do
and um but i would actually argue that
you know his his greatest work the
things that he's done that have been of
just this mind-blowing significance of
giving us
i mean he's completely revolutionized
some areas of mathematics
he's totally revolutionized the way we
understand the relations between
mathematics and physics
and most of those
his greatest work
is is stuff that doesn't have has little
or nothing to do with string theory i
mean for instance he um
you know he so he was actually one of
fields the very strange thing about him
in some sense is that he um he doesn't
have a nobel prize so there there's a
very large number of people who are
nowhere near as smart as he is when
don't work anywhere near as hard who
have nobel prizes i think he just had
the misfortune of
coming into the field at a time when
things had gotten much much much tougher
and nobody really had
no matter how smart you were it was very
hard to come up with a
new idea that was going to work
physically and get you a nobel prize
but he but he um you know he he got a
fields medal for
a certain work he did in um in
mathematics and that's just completely
unheard of you know for mathematicians
to give a field medal to someone outside
their field and physics is really um
you know you wouldn't have before it
he came around i don't think anybody
would have thought that was even
conceivable these things um
he came into the field of theoretical
physics at a time when um
and still to today
is you can't get a nobel prize for
purely theoretical work a specific
problem of trying to do better than the
standard the standard model is just
this insanely successful thing and it
kind of came together in 1973 pretty
much
and post and so and and all of the
people who kind of were involved in that
coming together you know many of them
ended up with nobel prizes for that but
but if you look
post 1973 pretty much it it's a little
bit more there's some edge cases if you
like but the if you look post 1973 at
what people have done to try to do
better than the standard model and to
get a better unified theory it really
hasn't it's been too hard a problem it
hasn't worked the theory is too good and
so it's not that other people
went out there and did and did it and uh
not him and that they got nobel prizes
for doing it no one really the kind of
thing he's been trying to do with string
theory is not um no one has been able to
do since 1973.
you